طلال الكريم لان العلاقات الامريكيه
الروسيه لا تزال وستظل سيئه وبان
الانتخابات في الكونجرس لن تؤثر على ذلك
بشان مزاعم لتدخل روسيا في الانتخابات
الامريكيه قال الكريم لان هو امر يعتاد
سماعه بالفعل وعشر الى انه من المبكر جدا
الحديث عن حوار معه واشنطن بشان تمديد
اتفاقيه ستار الجديده الكريم لان اضفنا
هناك مبالغه كبيره في اهميه انتخابات
الكون الامريكي بالنسبه للعلاقات الروسيه
الامريكيه الى ذلك اعلنا نائب رئيس مجلس
الاتحاد الروسي قسطنطينيه
مع المشرعين الامريكيين واوضح في السياق
ذاته في بيان ان الحوار بين الجانبين لم
ينقطع بمبادره من روسيا واشكرك في امكانيه
في الاتصالات بين مسرعيا البلدين واشار
الى غياب اي تغيرات في مواقفه اعضاء
الكونجرس واعضاء المجلس الامريكيين بسبب
اجماعهم على اتخاذه موقفه معادن لروسيا
بحسب قوله
للمتابعه تنضم الي من موسكو مراسله
الجزيره رانيا الدريدي يا مرحبا رانيا همم
سياق هذه التصريحات من الكريم والمسؤولين
الروس
وتاتي بالتاكيد بالتزامن مع بدايه ظهور
النتائج المتعلقه بالانتخابات تجديد
النصفي الامريكي
نعم محمد يعني كل هذه التصريحات تاتي
للحديث عن الموقف الروسي ازاء ما يجري في
داخل الولايات المتحده بشكل عام وايضا
فيما يتعلق بالنتائج الاوليه للانتخابات
الامريكيه يعني روسيا يعني اكدت ان هذه
الانتخابات على لسان الكرم لان هذه
الانتخابات بالفعل هي مهمه همم ولكن من
جهه اخرى اشار الكريم لانه لا يجب
المبالغه باهمي العلاقات لا سيما فيما
يتعلق بالجزئيه العلاقات
الى البلدين اشار الكريم التي تصريحاته
اليوم فان روسي عندما يبدو لا تعول كثيرا
على اي تغييرات في السياسه الامريكيه فضلا
عن ذلك اشار الى ان العلاقات الروسيه
الامريكيه لن تتغير لاعلى المستوى القريب
ولا على المستوى المتوسط هذه العلاقات
وصفهام للبيئه وستبقى كذلك في المرحله
المقبله اما فيما يتعلق بجزئيه التدخل في
الانتخابات همم يعني تبخل روسيا في هذه
الانتخابات يعني نحن نعلم روسي كانت قد
نفذ اي تدخل لها رسميا على مختلف على لسان
مختلف المسؤولين الروس على اللسان
الخارجيه والكريم وما الى ذلك ولكن اشار
الى انه يعني روسيا قد تعودت على كل هذه
الاتهامات التي تصدر بحقها من قبل الجانب
الاوكراني لدرجه محمد انها باتت لا
تلاحظها ولا تلي لها اي اا اهتمام بشكل
عام محمد انطلاقا من التصريحات الصادره
اليوم من موسكو روسيا تنظروا يعني الى ما
يجري حاليا في الولايات المتحده والى
نتائج هذه الانتخابات على انها ازمه
داخليه في الولايات المتحده اليوم رئيس
مجلس الدومه اشار الى ان ذلك مرتبط
بالدرجه الاولى بالمشكلات الاقتصاديه التي
تمر بها الولايات المتحده الى جانب همم
الانقسام في المجتمع الامريكي وايضا
الصراع على السلطه واشار لانه في حال لم
تتخذ الولايات المتحده تغيرات داخليه
وخارجيه جذريه فان هذه الازمه ست سنوات
ستتفاقم اكثر واكثر الاسئله بحلول
الانتخابات بس الرئاسيه الامريكيه عام
2024 من جهه اخرى هناك كانت ايضا تصريحات
لافته من قبل نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
بميتري مدريدي الذي اشار لان نتائج هذه
الانتخابات حسب تعبيره تشير الى ان اا
يعني عالم ما وصفه
الجد بايضا حسب وصفها وحسب تعبيره بات
يتطاير وان هذا دليل على ان العالم او ان
همم يعني مسار الولايات المتحده في العالم
حسب قوله باتي يتراجع اذا روسيا لا تعول
كثيرا على نتائج هذه الانتخابات في ما
يتعلق بالعلاقات مع الولايات المتحده همم
روسيا ترى ان ذلك هو النتائج الازمه
الداخليه في الولايات المتحده وفيما يتعلق
وايضا بجزئيه الاتصالات بين البلدين نحن
نعلم ان الكريم نفى وجود اي اتصالات بين
موسكو واشنطن لاسيما فيما يتعلق بشان
الامريكي نعم هناك اتصالات اكدت عليها
الخارجيه تتعلق بمساله همم السجناء وتبادل
السجناء بين البلدين لكن هناك موضوع في
غايه الاهميه وهو ما يتعلق بمعاهده ستارت
الحد من الاسلحه الاستراتيجيه الهجوميه
همم التي من المتوقع ان ينتهي مفعولها عام
2026 هذه الاتفاقيه هي من اهم الاتفاقات
في العالم يعني التي تحد بالانتشار
الاسلحه النوويه هذه همم الاتفاقيه تم
تمديدها بقدوم بيضا الى السلطه لمده خمسه
اعوام روسيا يعني اكدت خلال الفتره
الاخيره وقبل ذلك محمد انها مستعده لبحث
هذه هذه المساله مساله التمديدها او
التوصل الى همم اتفاقيه جديده مع الولايات
المتحده في هذا الشان الولايات المتحده
بدورها ايضا تؤكد استعدادها لتفاوض مع
روسيا في هذا الشان ولكن اليوم الكريم
الان قال انه من السابق له اوانه الحديث
عن اي اتصالات مع الولايات المتحده في هذا
الشان انه لا يمكن الاعلان عن مثل هذا
النوع من الاتصالات شكرا يا مدريدي ممثلات
الجزيره معنا من موسكو